the township of Soweto lies just south
of Johannesburg formerly a home to
miners the region now has around 4
million residents no one knows the exact
number most living corrugated sheet
metal shacks and that's just what young
entrepreneur London Louisville wants to
change he wants to have lots of brick
houses built 50,000 homes are needed in
the Johannesburg metropolitan area we
have a lot of people who come in to
Johannesburg coming to look for work
opportunities so most of them to
actually prefer to live in the townships
because it's cheaper to live there when
you're renting and it's actually
convenient for me to live from wherever
you staying too cold wet so this creates
an opportunity for homeowners to
actually create accommodation for those
people where they're renting the precast
structures either in a formal manner or
The Dispensing attract many South
Africans could never afford to buy a
home of their own so they rent shacks in
other people's backyards all crammed
together side by side landlady
Louisville is a self-taught bricklayer
while building an outbuilding in the
backyard of his parents home he got an
idea to replace corrugated metal shacks
with brick houses his customers are the
people who own the land they pay for the
building in monthly instalments using
the rent they receive from the tenants
while the tenants themselves get to live
in a better home plus the whole thing is
more environmentally friendly as the
houses are made of special bricks LEGO
bricks so because the interlocking you
actually use 70% less cement so this
actually cuts your building costs by up
to 30% you can use unskilled and
semi-skilled labor to actually build
with these bricks you only use a
qualified quickly maybe to the
Foundation's and just the rest of the
structure when you have to put in the
roofing land Lenovo makes his bricks out
of old construction waste so he doesn't
need to use sand
that also means the bricks don't have to
be fired in a kiln which saves on energy
because the building blocks are
interlocking the pressure of their own
weight is sufficient to make the walls
strong and stable
it's an unusual way to build but it's
less of a burden on the environment than
traditional masonry since we're not
using the traditional building method
most people were a bit skeptical when it
comes to interlocking bricks especially
when you tell them that you don't really
use cement to build structures so having
to have a pilot this is kind of like
unlocked potential tiles we now have
people because they can see touch and
feel the structure it's now more
convincing than for them to be even
interested in the technology this man
was also interested and happy to learn
more Savan Lisi beer is among the first
tenants to move into one of the brick
houses the 35-year old car mechanic has
been living in a backyard for six years
until recently in a metal Shack but not
anymore now he has a proper home
he used to pay about 35 euros a month
now he pays 40 he thinks it's worth it
actually I'm very very very happy
because if you're staying in the shack
is not like casting in their own
Shakey's like gay isn't it's not as a
place to be like he's a human being
actually just staying in a room it's a
you feel you're confident when
everything like shake is not their own
building rubble is a major environmental
problem in the impoverished districts of
Johannesburg many companies just dumped
their waste in the townships to avoid
pain disposal fees Nandu samosa BIA
knows this all too well every day dozens
of trucks come to her neighborhood to
illegally dump a building waste for more
prosperous areas this bothered her a lot
until it inspired her to become an
entrepreneur
now she's founded a startup that
processes waste
so because a lot of people doing waste
removal right they collect ways and then
their collectors but then we actually
take responsibility of where the waste
ends up we rehabilitate roads with the
waste we composted we also send it or
distributed to organization that make
use of us organizations like London
Lewis house building company the two
startups plan to work together de novo
could use the plentiful building rubble
for his environmentally friendly bricks
now the two are working on ways to crush
the waste and transport it to the
construction sites they hope to get
started soon working out how we can
actually collaborate and use the rubble
as raw materials for making bricks with
the the rubble and then it can be
actually more profitable on pomerode
mobile side and actually help hire more
people because then you'll need people
were going to make bricks and people
going to separate the waste and crush
Teresa's law more than 3 million
publicly subsidized homes have been
built in South Africa in the past 25
years even so the government has failed
to meet the need for new housing landed
a Louisville says that many who came to
Johannesburg hoping for a better life
are now living in worse housing than
before they're exactly the people he
wants to help and not just by building
new homes for them he has many more
ideas for the future
but therefore must perform assessments
the plan is to actually train the people
that live here have skill them to
actually build their own structures so
we can replace all the shacks by giving
them skills and also training them to
build their own houses these are two
areas which we are moving to another one
being the individual areas all that is
the stuff of the future right now each
building is a major financial risk for
London to Louisville and his startup
he's only been able to complete three
homes with environmentally-friendly
bricks so far three more are under
construction but he's been inundated
with requests for more
you